we all have regrets in life but chris
cuomo should have at least two
this was the actual swab that was being
used
to fit up that double barrel shotgun
that you have mounted
on the front of your pretty face do you
think
that you are an attractive person now
because you're single and ready to
mingle do you really think
you are some desirable single person and
that this is not just people's pain
coming out of them i think
beauty is in the eye of the beholder oh
those were the days
amidst the gushing liberal frenzy over
the kissing bandits press briefings
cnc in the muscle factory thought it
precious to exploit that moment
for his own ratings look everyone we're
related
his boss and producers let it fly as
thousands of people died in rest homes
that q-tip still grimly taunts the
victims families
how can you do a comedy routine as a
plague claims our loved ones
it's possible when you're the news you
control the spigot
your friends control the narratives and
when it gets bad just pretend the q-tip
and the creepy bro
never happened so last night cc in the
muscle factory steps away from the fray
obviously he must be aware of what's
going on with his brother
obviously i'm aware of what's going on
with my brother
and obviously i cannot cover it because
he is my brother now of course
cnn has to cover it they have covered it
extensively
and they will continue to do so
so when it's bad news chris won't cover
him but when it's good news have had it
if only that were the worst part of this
but it isn't seriously
why does the media and our politicians
see the sex harassment story
as a far bigger one than the rest home
deaths
sure unwanted kisses are creepy but
compared to thousands of deaths
now you want him to resign over kissing
but not death i don't get this is the
sex harassment story just a way to get
distance from the rest home outrage
or did the despised governor no longer
serve a use to a media
that needed him to get rid of trump
either way the media decides for you and
me
what gets clicks you've got sex and
you've got
death which is more fun to cover at
least chris cuomo
doesn't have to choose
just for our enjoyment katie i pulled
some headlines from a few months ago
uh cnn surprisingly says andrew cuomo
may be the single most popular
politician in america right now
vogue i love vogue for the political
writing the pandemic has spawned an
unlikely comedy duo
cuomo and cuomo and the washington post
cuomo could be the leader the democratic
party
and nation desperately need that's all
changed katie why could that be
yeah nobody's laughing now they aren't
so funny now i think it's outrageous
that they're making this excuse that
because they're brothers he can no
longer cover all the bad news that we've
seen come out of
the cuomo administration i do think that
the sexual harassment claims are
obviously a problem but that 15 000 dead
seniors as a result of a directive from
the governor which he then tried to
cover up is under who
is now under federal investigation and
democrats in the state are trying to
subpoena him to get information from him
is certainly the bigger story and so
we'll see what happens here but
definitely a distraction from the really
serious issue of people's families dying
and then him not giving any answers and
saying who cares they died
who cares what happened that's the issue
so dana here are some tweets from that
same period of time this is uh crazy
lady jennifer rubin
god i love tales from the cuomo's one of
the few joys in
all this chris talizza he works at cnn
andrew cuomo said he'll never run for
president
that's a mistake mark ruffalo actor
writes we as new yorkers are lucky to
have a leader like governor cuomo in
this crisis
where are they now dana where are they
now i'm sure they're thinking
that they uh don't think that he should
run for president now uh given that uh
yeah that is not going to happen but
remember at the time i said there are
most democrats who actually do not
actually like andrew cuomo he has a lot
of friends he's got a lot of enemies and
so you had the nursing home story which
wasn't getting enough attention getting
some you know
building especially after his aides said
that they uh slow walked the justice
department or even obstructive justice
so
there's an investigation there the cuomo
brothers were on
nine times now before that you know i
believe that there is freedom in
discipline
and in standards and if you stick to
your standards you won't have this
problem
but they didn't and i can't imagine how
you know the colleagues feel over there
that
they have to sit there and watch this
comedy routine and then now they can't
even have it covered in prime time
yeah juan what are your thoughts on this
well i think you know it's always a
mistake greg for brothers to interview
brothers sisters
uh business partners on a news show i
just think that's inappropriate
it's an opening to a conflict of
interest and i think that's what you got
here i think there's a clear
conflict of interest now i will say
we're all in the cable business we know
that entertainment and news
oftentimes gets fused and it can pump up
the numbers the ratings
but i think that here what you've got is
now it's come back to bite them big time
i think this is damaging to chris cuomo
and his show i think it's damaging
to the governor one way or the other and
by the way on the death part
i think he made a bad decision and we
can complain about it and he certainly
seems to have covered up the number of
debts but i think that's a policy
decision i think the reason people are
focused right now on something like the
sex scandal
is because it's immediate and provable
it's not a a judgment issue
this is something that's wrong you can't
do that with people who work for you
what do you think uh jesse last word to
you
well when i saw governor cuomo's nipple
rings
i knew it was trouble do we remember the
tight shot of the white
shirt you could see the piercings that
was a huge red
flag for the reminders cuomo knew about
those
rings anyway i had a lot more to say
about sexual harassment but i know we're
running out of time
and i'll save it for tomorrow wow well
done hearing about the nipple rings and
sexual harassment
yeah i'm glad you got your priorities
straight